le sergent yvonne huisne 33 ans est la
première femme de l'armée française tués
au sahel depuis 2013 le brigadier loïc
risser et est lui âgé d'à peine 24 ans
tous deux engagés dans un régiment
spécialisé dans le renseignement
le véhicule blindé de ces deux
militaires a sauté ce samedi sous un
engin explosif artisanal
c'était lors d'une mission de
reconnaissance de l'opération barkan
dans la région de ménaka au mali
un troisième soldat français a également
été blessé lors de cette attaque mais
ses jours ne sont pas en danger
la france a perdu deux de ses enfants
je rends hommage à la force de
l'engagement du sergent even usines et
du brigadier loïc risser du 2e régiment
de hussards de haguenau il incarne
l'honneur et la bravoure des hussards de
chamboux rang mes pensées vont à leurs
familles
la motivation la pugnacité et
l'abnégation des militaires français
demeurent intactes face aux groupes
terroristes filière de déchets d'al
qaïda qui s'aiment terreur est ko au
mali et au sahel dans un communiqué de
l'elysée le président français salue
également la mémoire des deux soldats
morts dans leur mission emmanuel macron
qui réaffirme que paris continuera coûte
que coûte à se battre contre le
terrorisme au sahel
le président de la république réaffirme
la détermination de la france dans son
combat contre le terrorisme
il salue le courage de nos soldats et
les assure de sa confiance et de son
soutien face à cette nouvelle épreuve
une nouvelle épreuve douloureuse pour la
france ont à peine une semaine
lundi dernier trois soldats de l'armée
française sont tombés dans les mêmes
circonstances au mali le brigadier-chef
tannerie maury et les chasseur de 1ère
classe d'orient issac aniane et quand
empocher une attaque à la bombe
artisanale revendiquer ce samedi par la
branche d'al qaïda au sahel
ces soldats français mené leur toute
première mission depuis à peine deux
mois dans la zone des trois frontières
région où se rencontrent le mali le
burkina faso et le niger en janvier
dernier à l'issue du sommet de pau la
france a engagé six cents soldats
supplémentaires au sahel portant ses
effectifs environ 5000 101 ans après ce
renforcement militaire paris examine
en ce moment l'évolution de cet
engagement la france pourrait amorcer un
début de retrait de ses troupes dans la
zone des trois frontières
pour l'instant aucun calendrier officiel
n'a été arrêté malgré la série noire ces
derniers jours qu'ils touchent
l'opération barkan